hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to mr. Musashi Jonny yeah
great bastard it's your old mate Oliver
here listen the noise is young and sir
v/o loading my man guns my profile
there's a sexy guy in my phone oh it's
just me well that sounds like me I've
got a match
hi honey I'm so glad you made it this
means a lot to me you know what that's
literally racist buddy yeah I am a
werewolf oh my gosh so once I did that
stable boy and you had a pet duck it
emphasizes on the Hat I just couldn't
resist a delicious-looking Dutch I'm a
mega ducks out there been nothing but
charming and understanding and only
slightly racist tonight so you know what
I want you to be the first guy welcomed
into my cage
[Music]
[Applause]